today i am joined by james cromwell
actor activist producer whose new film
mondo hollywoodland follows a
politically confused mushrooms dealer
who traverses through hollywood
available now on amazon prime video
uh james so great to have you on i
really appreciate it thank you
so
talk to us a little bit about this this
film which you produced um what what was
the genesis of the idea here
uh the genesis of the idea was that uh
maybe it made him
easier for him to sell the film
i love the honesty i love it
which matters a lot which matter it's
not a small issue
no it is not not if you want your film
to be seen
um can you talk a little bit about the
60s era mondo films that that this movie
is sort of an homage to
um and and sort of what you see is
interesting about the the genre
well i i think uh if i if i have my
genres right it's a new velvag um
it's uh gadard and chebral and varda and
truffaut
the new wave they called it uh i think
of this film sort of as the butter soup
which is goddard's film only in color
um
there were
there are stories that goddard actually
knew
that what he was doing was bad but that
was the whole point
um so he was trying to look at the
language of film
uh and develop a new syntax a new way of
making films sort of the way bertold
breck does with what it's called ver
fremdom's effect which is to distance an
audience to keep them aware that it is
filmic that it is a film it is a fiction
it is a narrative it relates
to something that is up for the audience
to create for themselves
in in hearing you talk in in this way
about films
i'm sort of
i'm realizing and i wonder if you agree
that this type of analysis of film has
become
sorely lacking sort of in popular
culture in the united states at this
point in time
uh do you agree with that i mean it's it
seems to me that the richness of the
discussion of film
um in this style is not what it once was
in in popular society
certainly in america yeah because in
america film is considered a product a
studio has a certain pro studio works is
owned by a corporation that corporation
has obligations to its shareholder to
produce a profit they produce
this thing called a film cinema
they show the cinema and they try to
reach as broad an audience as possible
so they either play down to that
audience or through the media that they
also control they create reviews that
make the thing seem as vacuous as
possible right so let's not send anybody
before they they're sitting in the seats
watching it so there's two layers in
other words the film is created in a
certain way
but the discussion of that film and its
promotion could still be more
substantive but even that in order to
make the film appealing is is kept
relatively superficial so you really
have two layers of this that you're
fighting against
yeah if you think of a film like joker
and you think well are they going to
take are they going to take that film
seriously
you know some people
which i'm really glad were offended by
that film but there's a lot to unpack in
that film there's a lot of discussions
about who we are where we are what we're
doing are we insane
who runs the show
what can we do as individuals to oppose
it what is the cost of living in a
dysfunctional society when your
entire mental
structure is uh is cobbed together from
falsehood
i remember uh watching an interview
where charlie rose interviewed the late
david foster wallace and they were just
chatting about different things and
charlie rose asks david foster wallace
his opinion about the english patient
and after sort of in that that david
foster wallace sense of saying you
really care what i think about the
english patient is that real do you are
you really asking me that
he says i think it's
a beautifully filmed commercial
hollywood endeavor that was sort of like
his top line analysis that fundamentally
it's still it it looks nice but it's a
profit-driven hollywood endeavor
is is your top line analysis of a film
similar where first you're you're
looking at what what was the point of
the production here was it an
independent project was a profit driven
project hollywood etc
that that enters into my thinking um
also the way that certain
um what would i call them um
not metaphors but when they use
contemporary situations circumstances
events that really happened or real
people exploitatively without examining
what they're doing they just use it
because it it gives a patina of reality
of of pertinence
um and uh i think it's a great mistake
people do that with the with the
holocaust they do that with
the nazis they do that in a variety of
ways the politics are always what it
comes down to is it's basically a boy
meets girl boy loses girl boy gets girl
but saw a film like siriana which has
many many many many many many layers
yeah and it's very provocative if you
think about it gets short shrift because
they know
the powers that be is that an audience
is not going to be able to analyze that
film from
an understanding of the what the reality
is so they'll miss half the film and say
what was that all for i don't understand
i like george clooney he's so funny why
can't he do
and you think wow that's uh that's a
waste it's so interesting that that that
you mentioned that movie because that's
one that i've thought about in this
context where when you look at the
analysis and the discussion of it
it it's it's talking about 20 or 30
percent of the film and and like you're
pointing out there's so much substance
there that seems to be above the radar
in a sense or below i don't know
yeah i agree um when it comes to
you mentioned
the holocaust for example as as one uh
uh topic sometimes that's touched in
certain ways and not others i just
finished up reading the book technopoly
by the critic neil postman where he
talks about in the education context in
the united states and this book was
written in 1992 but still relevant
there's often agreement about what are
valuable topics in school and the
holocaust is one that is considered we
teach about the holocaust we teach about
slavery etc similarly in in literature
there are often
books or authors where there's a sort of
consensus like it's important that
students read this
but less commonly is there really
thought given to
what is it that we want people to learn
and then how should they
use this in their lives going forward
like what's the point what do we want
people to take away from learning about
the holocaust or whatever the case may
be is that
uh
applicable to film as well when some of
these
events or ideas are used just to make a
move a movie excuse me
uh yes i think i think it is um
i did a film
called the
panama papers i think it was called the
papers
and uh
it was interesting because the
panama papers revelations
it seemed to exclude every american
there was no american mention
and there's no real connection to an uh
there was a an event in america but it
was the the uh it wasn't central to what
the story was about which was how this
uh catastrophe uh occurred and i know
i'm noticing the same things in this new
revelation the pandora papers
that it's all about kenyatta of of kenya
and somebody in czechoslovakia
and all these people then they say and
celebrities and i don't know what the
that consortium of uh independent
journalists thought was happening with
people who have a great deal of money
because that's what they do
they make very clear that there's no um
there's no criminality involved but at
the same time they don't show you the
whole story which is two of our states
delaware and
um
south dakota are are probably two of the
biggest offshore uh deposits of um
people's money uh that there are yeah so
so in other words in almost any time
film is a very simple medium
if you overlay it with a lot of fact if
there's a lot of levels to understanding
it's very hard to keep an audience
because an audience is only interested
not only in the narrative but seeing
themselves in the character so that they
can experience the thing that the things
that the character does and they play
this sort of game isolated by themselves
whereas you get a film like the battle
of algiers which i saw back in the 60s
you know movie house in new york and uh
there were black panthers uh in the
front row right right in front of me and
of course they understood every nuance
of that film because they'd seen it in
their community but i a nice white boy
sitting behind him i'm looking at this
film it's revelatory but i know nothing
about
how the police how the state operates in
a ghetto to suppress the aspirations of
the people
right
um a couple of things i wanted to ask
about maybe related to this you've been
arrested several times doing activism
it's typically like trespassing basic
civil disobedience
does that have any long-term impact in
any kind of legal sense do those arrests
matter because they're not they don't
rise to the level interestingly enough
of where you start falling subject to
like a three strikes and you're out sort
of thing does it have any impact at all
on you well actually it does in texas
um the one i have in texas i'm still on
probation wow
it means that i cannot i get arrested in
any state for breaking any law
and
you know it
if i
had a larger
a career i suppose that i would be like
some
wonderful people in hollywood who
actually do do really great work
i'm not sure that sean penn
uh gets the opportunities to do the work
now that he did before
because of the work that he did in haiti
and the enemies that he made in haiti
namely the clinton foundation and um
and the united nations and what he saw
and how he reacted to it and how he
spoke about it so
i i don't know um my activism i don't
think raises to that rises to that level
but people do notice
uh and um
it is a valid tech it is a technique of
civil disobedience
uh breaking the law in order to bring
attention to the law
uh to to crimes that are being being
committed inside of the law
um and uh there will be ramifications to
my career there may be but i i can't
stop it i have to continue doing what
i'm doing no doubt no doubt
um you were a bernie supporter are you
what's your sense so far of joe biden's
uh presidency
how many haitians has he set back
how what's he doing at the border
what's he what listen this was the same
with obama obama had both both houses of
congress he had the presidency he did
absolutely squat
i don't think much changes between that
administration and what it managed to
accomplish since it until it got into
the sort of stalemate that's going to
exist in 2022 when the republicans take
back the house we're going to be in the
same bloody position
it the change as as
toonberry says and other young
environmentalists say
it's not going to come from the blah
blah blah of politicians it's going to
come from the street it's going to come
from the demands of people and uh
i think uh i think that will happen so
you don't think too highly so far of
what of what joe biden has done clearly
do you do you distinguish between
is there a consequence to the fact that
it's joe biden and not another four
years of trump
it's not another four years of trump but
we all in the 60s we also say yeah but
it's so much it's so much like it under
the surface when you watch the policies
what's happening around the world what
when are we going to start
it looks like we're trying to start a
war with china but what's going to
happen
around the world to this war state that
we have created to satisfy the needs of
the military-industrial complex we need
those wars we need those bases i just
watched the film on the f-35 the f-35
the development of the f-35 is going to
cost
over 1 trillion dollars between 1 and
1.7 trillion dollars they're they're
being sold at 180 million dollars a
piece what what are we doing as we head
towards the precipice of environmental
destruction what are we doing
supporting this industry those
industries and
the extraction industries
so he's open he just opened up a whole
new drilling thing off the coast of the
off the west coast after they had that
oil spill caused by a ship dragging its
anchor and puncturing a pipe yeah
there's no way to have
this system and i by that this system i
mean capitalism
have a democratic solution
to the problems that all the problems
that heal us
the environment racism sexism
across the lot nothing is going to
change as long as people put profit
ahead of people do you see these systems
in places like denmark norway and sweden
as sufficiently different or is that not
enough
no
i think it's sufficiently different
it's not a no it's not enough it needs
to be examined however if we had the
system of the scandinavian countries we
could at least have a dialogue about
what's happening in this country right
what's happening to the people who feel
so disaffected that they attacked the
congress of the united states violently
to achieve what
they their lives were not appreciably
made better by that man's
uh presidency so what what are they
thinking are they thinking or are they
being led by an australian named murdoch
to not be able to distinguish the truth
from falsehood when it's right in their
faces and it's them yeah
he's the worst
he's up there for sure he is up there
for sure yeah we've been speaking with
actor and activist james cromwell the
new film is mondo hollywoodland james i
so appreciate being able to speak with
you the film is now available on amazon
prime video and we're linking to it uh
real really a pleasure speaking with you
today
likewise enjoy the film it's really a
wonderful film see it